we got this from we have the story from
538 california's gavin newsom will
likely face a recall election
but he'll probably survive it he wrote
that 538 sounds like propaganda well i
know i was going to say that because 538
failed miserably in the 2020 election
and the 2016 election
and they were so mad about it what was
that one well all the polls were
historically off
by like what was it what was the average
like seven points
it was worse in 2020 than it was in
2016. my favorite thing about the polls
was the new york times had safe democrat
lean democrat
toss-up lean republican safe republican
and the whole thing
skewed red cube republican so the lean
democrat
all went republican and then the safe
democrat actually some seats flipped
republican
that's why they were able to regain a
lot of the house they were so wrong
so now it is true let me let me read a
little bit of the story just give you
guys context they say
california governor gavin newsom has
been in office for just two years
but there have already been five failed
attempts to force a statewide recall
election on whether to remove him from
office
that itself is unusual california has
some of the most permissive recall
requirements in the country
but what is you what is unusual is that
the sixth attempt which is currently
underway appears to be gaining some
serious traction
if it makes the ballot the election
would be just the fourth gubernatorial
recall election in all of american
history
and two of the previous three governors
to face recalls ended up going down
in defeat including california's in 2003
when in the midst of a statewide fiscal
crisis 55 percent of voters opted to
recall democrat gray davis
and elected republican arnold
schwarzenegger in the fir in his place
that seems like a bad omen for newsome
until you consider
for special circumstances of this recall
and the political evolution of
california well i'm not interested
in their overall assessment the point is
it's
everyone else has lost and uh it's over
what 1.5 million signatures now to get
rid of new sun
yeah so he could be gone i mean just
what it shows is how angry people
are i mean i don't think you can
look at what's happening in california
which is we are the most locked down
place la specifically is the most locked
down
and yet we're the worst of the cases
there was a story that the air
that people in l.a were breathing was
like polluted with uh from the what's it
called when they burned people the
crematorium crematoriums yeah really
that the air was so polluted because
people were dying at such a frequent
rate and but what's so crazy is that
you know obviously there is a growing
movement of people who are angry about
the leadership in california but there
are still so many people there that
think it's like
he's doing a great job simply because
he's democrat and they look at florida
and they look at desantis and they're
like oh my god i can't believe they're
fully open that's so messed up and it's
like
but they're not worse off than us so
what is the logic
at this point if you support lockdowns
and the way that they've been imposed
i think there's something seriously
wrong with you it's a cult it really is
when they when they complain about trump
supporters and they're like
you know i see these posts on facebook
all the time they're like trump
supporters you're in a cult
i'm like you know okay i i know the
people they're referring to
they're referring to the q people who
believe this crazy nonsense
i understand why they're saying that my
response to them is usually like i hear
you i hear you
do you think you're in a cult you don't
have you have you have you
considered maybe y'all are crazy
the right and these and these these
really zealous trump supporters
don't have cultural power in the
cultural institutions and they had very
limited political power with trump as
president trump was struggling in a lot
of ways to do a lot of things
he was able to pull off a lot don't get
me wrong right now the democrats control
every cultural institution and every
branch of government well
except for the supreme court but we'll
see what happens they're fairly
pro-establishment
we'll see how they end up ruling and
look where we're at everyone's still
begging for
scraps from the government after almost
a year in a pandemic where people can't
afford food rent to survive and yet for
some reason some people still just like
are so much more comfortable with
democratic leadership and they don't get
it
it's a cult you know so i'm not saying
everybody would have
voted for democrats i thought that's
ridiculous every trump supporter wasn't
some zealous conspiracy
conspiracy theorist it's just that in
the cultural institutions
you have substantially more cult-like
democrat people
who just would absolutely watch the
whole country burn down
if it meant they were owning the cons
you have a similar
element among right-wingers for sure but
they don't have any power
they're not that's why that's why i've
never really cared to be like oh so that
you know that that q guy you know he
said something dumb on twitter i don't
care
he doesn't control the entirety of the
party he doesn't control hollywood or tv
shows or
digital marketing and he's not
controlling a branch of government
now it's it's all democrats it's the
liberal economic order they started at
the british and the americans started it
after world war ii to basically
control the world with military so
there's like this military
you know propaganda effort that's
controlled by this
liberal force that could be the economic
i don't think liberal makes them make
sense because actually
the specific term is liberal economic
orders right i i i know but i mean like
they call themselves liberal
republicans and democrats are doing the
same thing you know the
the the republican party the democratic
party are are working towards the same
goal i think the republicans are just
like a caricature of a villain
where they do literally nothing but
obstruct in certain ways to make
democrats angry and never actually fight
for causes that the people on the right
actually want
right so when trump came around and said
i'm gonna fight for you they're like
finally somebody
and then trump did some things and
ultimately didn't get a lot through
because
he was obstructed at every turn even his
own administration his own
administration
apparently the reason trump didn't get
on parlor or gab was because of jared
kushner
who was like don't do it don't go on
don't don't do it okay well now he's
gone now he can't say anything
we've got in this country democrats in
states like california
in places like new york pushing policies
and winning elections while people
suffer and beg for scraps like you were
mentioning
and and the reason why i say it's a cult
is because no matter what happens
they will not let it go i had a friend
sent them
the time magazine you see the time
magazine article about the shadow
campaign blair
yeah am i how much more explicit could
they make it
right when they said a shadow campaign a
conspiracy in the background by an elite
cabal of powerful individuals
started in fall of 2019 mind you which
means they were doing it to bernie
sanders
to ensure the proper outcome and my
friend was like oh but they were just
fortifying the election and i said you
realize
the democratic primary didn't conclude
until 2020 which means they were doing
it to bernie sanders
and then all of a sudden they were like
yeah i'm like
yeah did you notice they were it wasn't
about trump
trump was a part of it it's about the
people getting an actual candidate who
represented them
unfortunately bernie sold out he wants
to be a millionaire you know that's why
i feel so disaffected between the left
versus right thing now
at this point it's if you don't at some
point if you don't start seeing that
it's the elites versus
the people then i don't really know
what's wrong with you especially the
last year the last year has revealed so
much about just
the way the system works the ways in
which it's broken the ways in which
it doesn't just not serve the people but
it actively crushes the people
that you have so many people that still
vote for that same
system and what's really scary is that
now that biden's in power
we talked about this earlier now it's
back to sort of the
obama era of like just complete um
like not even caring about politics at
all what's the right word like blind
ignorance and obedience combined like
complaining
but it's but it's not even devotion it's
because they don't they don't actually
like binding good point
no one likes but it's not even
compliance it's like it's like
subservience
complacency complacency hold on but it's
like
a willful disregard of information
yes and a and willful ignorance to allow
biden to do whatever he wants and turn
away and not pay attention anymore i
think the word is witness
a blind witness because he's a democrat
so nothing he does is going to be bad
and everything anyone is republican does
is i know you know you know what i loved
about obama was when uh
when when he ran and you know anti-war
and all that stuff and i voted for him i
was all excited
and then i think it was january 23rd of
2009 i could be getting the data day
wrong like only a few days after
inauguration
he ordered a drone strike on a village
of women and children killing civilians
and i was just like i felt like my heart
sink like
he he was supposed to say no he was
supposed to know and then i would go to
my friends
and all of a sudden all these anti-war
activists were just all of a sudden like
i don't know i don't know what you're
talking about i don't care
um we're gonna go get pizza at the bar
and just have a drink it's the same
thing now the war drums are starting to
beat up again
with biden and it's like where is
everyone that cares
no one okay no one i guess no one it's
like it's like the dominoes are falling
down
yeah and we're watching it happen and we
can't do anything to stop it
the whole the whole thing's gone well
even if people did rise up or
or did voice their disgust you wouldn't
know about it because your algorithm is
curated
your timeline is carefully selected to
make sure that
you see and have a perception that these
elite billionaires want you to see and
blair you made a very good
point it's something that i've been
screaming about for years now
endlessly i've been ridiculed and
attacked for it but it's not left versus
right it's you
versus the secret club of billionaires
and that's exactly what's happening
right now and these billionaires
they're getting their way they're
getting their their power they're
getting their money
more than they ever did before because
of these lockdowns and then we have
individuals like bill gates that by the
way
just recently became the largest
farmland owner
in all of the united states seriously
lecturing us
about how we need to lock down more
congratulating china about doing us a
great job
but also just as of today became the
biggest
shareholder in the canadian national
railroad
what a major yes a major railroad
company that doesn't doesn't just
provide
transportation services for all of
canada but also along the mississippi
from the north
to the south of the united states and
literally he's on his way from almost
controlling the entire food supply chain
from farm to table
and bill gates is buying up more assets
buying up more companies
buying up more land than ever before
who'd have thought bill gates would be
the reincarnation of alexander the great
we're conquering conquering large swaths
of territory around the world
largest shareholder of the canadian
national railroad
could you could you imagine sorry just
like i'm thinking about the
the legends of like genghis khan and
alexander the great riding in on
horseback and conquering land
and now we have this great warlord
conqueror and it's bill gates saying
well i recently purchased in a sweater
vest right
to add insult to injury yeah i mean this
man was was described as a ruthless
businessman
who changed his ways was going to donate
all of his money to charity
uh almost more than doubled his money by
the way uh but but he's the one that
that all the mainstream media guys are
are going for for the expert advice
about what to do next he also pushed the
goal post because a couple months ago he
said that
these lockdowns kovid's going to be be
with us until 2021.
he changed his stance now he's saying
2022 and of course who who benefits off
of these lockdowns
billionaires like him i saw you know
what gets me is that like i feel like
the left is always talking about class
consciousness and it's like i'm down
to have that conversation but it's like
so y'all support these lockdowns and you
don't see how the rich is getting richer
you're getting poorer i just saw an
article the top hundred billionaires
most wealthy
their wealth has increased by forty
percent since uh
absolutely you know what's funny is
there's we did mention this before but i
love this moment where tucker carlson
was doing his handoff with john hannity
and tucker was talking about how these
massive corporations value is
skyrocketing him in this lockdown
basically saying how it's the largest
transfer of wealth from the working
class to the wealthy
in in the history of humanity and then
when he's doing the handoff hannity goes
if a business provides a service and
makes money well then good for them
they're allowed to do it
and tucker's response was the tucker
face where he's like looking like huh
yeah the labrador like what i love that
interaction
how was it that tucker carlson had this
evolution on on populism and
you know the elites versus the people
and and it's just it's basically him
the the the rest of cable tv and
everybody are still very much
pro-establishment
well that's why they're trying to
counsel him so much right yeah
the stuff that he talks about is is very
important he talks about it i don't
always agree with him but he does it
from an honest perspective he does it
from an honest way
and he points out how it's not private
enterprise these
these are not businesses engaging in the
free market
these are quasi extensions of the
government
working with government hand in hand
pushing and
and making sure the game is rigged
against everyone else so they get their
way and they've been getting their way
non-stop and it's so sad how no one
thinks to take it that far in their mind
when they're looking around at them and
they're seeing
all of their fellow citizens living like
dogs on their
on their knees i will swore thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you